hello my children this is the last of
the nostalgia critic retrospectives that
I'm gonna put on the website before we
just start jumping into demo reel so I
was trying to think about what would be
the best thing to talk about certainly
talked about the worst movies ever so
the best reviews decided let's talk
about just my top 11 favorite moments uh
which is really tough because I was
going through a list gotten me a lot of
hideo's I was going through a list of
the reviews a life's a funny moment I
remember that moment a lot of habla I
came up with something like 27 it was
like okay so there's a lot of jokes that
really like so just keep in mind you
don't see like your favorite on there is
something chances are it was like it's
just it has to just deal heaven so yeah
these are pretty much out of all the
ones I could think of I went through
these are my top 11 favorite funniest
moments
[Music]
number one
Bonni boobies if you don't remember this
is the first time in the Space Jam
review where I talk about the fact that
they pretty much gave they sexualized a
rabbit you know in a Looney Tunes
cartoon I mean and it's not like just a
foil for bugs to go oh you know or
something like that I mean just a walk
off character or something I mean it was
like one of the main characters and it's
just I like this joke because I start
seeing this go around for a while and
it's diminished a bit you know because
people are just like okay wait a minute
personnel with - oh we can write that
for the longest time especially around
that time period for whatever reason a
lot of these writers got the idea in
kids program that's like you know just
we don't not even kids program a lot
programming we don't know how to write a
female character like they're aliens
like there are foreign race and it's
always it just fascinates me because
it's like write it the same way you know
I don't say the same we write a guy but
in the same way that whatever makes a
male character interesting do that with
the female well this guy is funny
because he's a doofus it doesn't know
any better
my current doofus doesn't know any
better so he's this fear I'm getting on
track okay so this is the first
sexualized you know bunny I've seen in a
movie this is before I knew about you
know some people that I make a joke
saying like look we don't want to fuck
bunnies and the internet had said show
me that there are quite a few who want
I mean that's neither here or there uh
you know for uh you know people that go
just wanna see Looney Tunes do their
thing you know they want to see the
looming toons be Looney and just seeing
this it was as much like the bunny
boobies as much as they're just trying
to make a sexualized Looney tune with no
other personality and not even a funny
sexy it's just like no you're
legitimately supposed to find her hot
it's just like dude like the first
female Looney tune you really have
outside of granny you know who is never
a main character uh they actually
created this character you can start
from scratch you got to work with
anything and you just make it a slutty
bitch
nothing doer and I thought just by
throwing these being arrested all the
early tools are naked practically I mean
it's like if you to take it off
shit they probably have nipples it'd be
like the Batman suit let's see about
that Schumacher bad man soon it's like
there's no purpose keep it you know bad
writers of female characters and Joel
Schumacher the nipples don't make a
character that's a very odd thing I have
to explain but you know this does not
replace this you know I'm sure for some
people very desperate it does but for
the rest of the thinking world that
wants to be entertained you know it it
really doesn't so um and I'm not going
into a hole I know I'm gonna get people
so you're magic furries I don't
understand first I don't care you know
whatever does it free it doesn't free if
it's sexual if it's not I don't care
it's the same thing with like brownies
and stuff I think you like it like it
who gives a fuck it's more that this is
the Looney Tunes like the most you know
some of the most iconic characters of
all time you're throwing this sexual
life bimbo into it
no bimbo would be funny that she's like
she didn't work our way up to bimbo like
the new lonely tunes that that was a
good addition whether you like this show
we're not that noble aim to show had a
great lullaby in it started what to name
from bridesmaids on blank our name
you're gonna yell at me later but that's
a great character and they did that well
Space Jam did not and I think that sums
up why they botched it up so yeah that's
one of my favorite moments
[Music]
the tomandjerry mindfuck and the Tom and
Jerry Hamlet quote I can't pick on this
one I like these both equally so again I
have to cheat upon the same slide but
there's stuff there from the same review
um the first one is when Tom and Jerry
first talk and it involves me spitting
first spitting out water then spitting
out watermelon with sangria that I'd be
drinking both at the same time just
forcing a joke to the nth degree and
putting saran wrap on the camera so I
wouldn't fly you know would hurt the
camera it actually slides down freely
it's great um and then it leads into
this great synthetic we about what Tom
Jerry was and what it meant and what
this movie has done to it and so on and
so forth and I like that moment because
it's a legitimate it's very funny it's
of course taking it something that
really doesn't matter you know what Tom
and Jerry who cares this bit to the Tom
and Jerry movie nobody saw it so it's
not like it destroyed you know an
enterprise or anything we still have you
Joel cartoons but at the same time it's
taking something I really loved and just
doing something so stupid with it so
it's kind of showing the real love I
have for that cartoon and the respect I
have for it and acknowledging it in the
most silly over-the-top poetic way you
know I mean it is essentially a poem in
Shakespeare and manipulating the lines
from Hamlet to represent that and
showing the it's I mean it's obviously
referencing Hamlet the one I
specifically referencing is the kenda
Branagh Wonka that's my favorite film
version and and it dissolves to you know
obviously it's him playing the skull of
a jester it dissolves to the gesture and
how they used to have fun and play along
and stuff like that and then back to the
skull and it's the same thing it's
showing images of Tom and Jerry and what
it used to be and how grand and was it
just this piece of shit did to it so
that's great I love that because also
shows the love I have for Tom and Jerry
the other one is when just this chasing
is going on in the
a third of it and it's so bad fucking
shit crazy you just can't believe what
you're watching and it's going so fast
and so crazy I know they're trying to
make it look like you know oh isn't this
wacky how did it get to this silly turn
of events me you're just like no how did
this occur this is pure insanity and I
have concerns for the person who came up
with it and pretty much what we did is
that I that's the first time I use the
term mindfuck which I'm sure that term
existed before me but is the first time
I used into the video and we are playing
but I'm not sick but I'm not well song
just to the images of the chase and me
like I lost my mind and it's one of
those things where it's just like I
think as we were watching it we were
just laughing at the insanity of what we
were watching and how so we kind of knew
what they were trying to get across it
was making us laugh but not for the same
reasons I think they wanted and it just
thinking every time I think of that JC
that how insane it is I mean not like oh
isn't that silly but no mentally insane
you know whoever came up with this you
know had a lobotomy
you know or was dropped as a child I
don't know but bottom line you know
something obviously affected this there
were these riders to come up with this
and they're just not well they're not
safe but they're not well I get night
they're sick so just when I think I've
seen I think in a music it just gets a
big laugh out of me I think it's the
first time ever done something like
we've given up or we've gone insane if
you can't beat them join them you know
kind of thing and I love those and it
gives me a chance to act silly and speed
up the film and stuff so both those
moments really gonna be
[Music]
the ghost of Christmas future from babes
in toyland not only is Jim trochus
performance as this goes great actually
he came up to me one day he was supposed
to be one of the cloaks from the
suburban knife but the scheduling I had
to change that didn't allow that and it
and he had this voice and this really
great voice and he always said he wanted
to be like the Grim Reaper or something
and I just want to write a character
around that so I came around I came up
with this idea that everyone always does
a Christmas Carol parody like everyone
in comedy does a Christmas carol parody
and it makes sense it's a great story
there's a lot of variations you can do
with it there's a lot of different
angles you can do with it uh and I was
found like nah but everybody does it but
let's make the joke that I won't do it
in that something's actually trying to
make me do it like the goat the jokes
already started but I won't play along
with it I won't go with it and the first
ghost that pops up is so determined to
make this joke happen
thank he's popping up in the review just
like I mean in the interrupting other
jokes to make this joke come true and it
just cracks me up I look but my favorite
I think the one that makes me like piss
my pants is when he comes up with the
ghost of Christmas famous okay sir
that's so much I figure that I think
it's a good life in acting as the puppet
and then you see it's him and him
marching and you know into the movie
actually trying to insert himself into
the movie trying to say that obscurus
loop is on board and then CNAs
frantically kidnapped her and then
there's another spin on that joke too so
it's and then then getting drunk at the
end oh love it it's like a review itself
is you know like an okay review you know
in the movie is so spectacular ly bad
but those elements are just gold to me I
think those just place oh well and that
voice is so funny the performance is so
funny I think the idea of interrupting
this joke is so funny oh really really
low
[Music]
number
that credit card and you're probably
thinking to yourself I'm sick to death
of this joke it parts of me kind of are
divided then again as I always say if
this is the worst part of my job
or like I just have to be used to having
people shout bag credit card to a that's
a pretty damn good job and I can't be a
whiny bitch about that um and honestly I
think it is a buddy Joe guy I think it
really did sum up just the final burnt
bridge for the host movies I mean not
that it could really recover from the
first whatever half of that film but as
soon as that came up it's like no
there's it's the point of no return
you've there's a stoker but there's no
going back
you've changed things forever you're
just afraid I mean it's like just that
was the nail in the coffin and I
remember that's what that it was just
that moment when I saw it when I was
like in high school and I wasn't liking
the movie but it was just no you really
have no idea how this works do you and I
think the reactions off of um you know
that the doctor coming in and constantly
you know trying to restrain me or
whatever it just helped how many times
it keeps going you think he's gonna go
back to the review but that he flips out
again and yeah I I don't know it that
image or that card or whatever it was as
infamous as it was before I came along a
prior to any boyfriend myself but I
never heard anybody talk about it um
really until I strike that even while I
was talking about the movie I'd always
tell people Vermeer the bad credit card
and they always go for white really
what's that in there oh I'd say I just
want they sure people never forget you
never forget that bad credit card just
say it still sounds funny maybe that's
why I made people yelling and stuff it
does sound so funny and it's it's a good
joke it's probably one the biggest freak
as ever
and it is well the earliest free cats so
it's hard not to acknowledge it and you
know if someone shouts at econo I'll
still do the back garden gallon giant
pungent and stuff that's my voice is
sore I do tell some people I'm just like
you know sorry man up in yellow we get
cab
Oh whispering so it's still a good joke
yeah you know I think maybe it is one of
those like you know it's a joke you
heard over and over and over you start
to get sick of it but then when you give
it a while you come back - it's pretty
funny
so um I do like it and I think it's a
lot of people's favorite Joe's not quite
my favorite but it's it's good stuff
[Music]
fucking bubbles yeah I I almost wish I
could just put all the commercial series
hey you know in here because I think the
commercials are so funny it was such a
good series and it was hard to pick
weights one because I can't do them all
from there but it's time to figure out
which one was the funny as I was just
like now it's gotta be it's gotta be
fucking bubbles you know and I don't
know why it's one of those I mean the
commercial you pretty much out of the
commercial you know where it's like this
kid is left you know he's the new kid in
the neighborhood and everyone's just
like yeah whatever catches him and but
he has bubbles all said it was just like
wow it's like he has like a crowd you
know he can feel like a stadium with
people that he's showing bubble thing to
I called it bubble and he's just going
around and all the kids it's like
they're looking at Jesus they're just
looking like whole so I found a few
donut bubbles are I mean it's like and
you know so of course I mean I just kept
playing up you know like this one kit
has a Nintendo and bubbles all the
problems god I've been healed thanks to
bubbles and it just every time I see it
the one that gets the funniest part just
the very last line you know a bubble
thing from lab or whatever you just here
in this very faint and something about
that faint fucking bubbles gets the
biggest laugh and I probably abused it
in other videos I've used it too much
for I guess bubbles keep popping up in
the movies ever view for some reason so
I've had to use it a few times and yeah
there's just what else can you see
fucking bubbles
[Music]
the aliens from signs now what I mean
specifically by this is when they're
trying to sneak into the house and this
is that point where I'll sort of telling
myself I want to sort of keep away from
just dumping over the movie just doing
the Mystery Science Theater like I want
to actually sort of analyze it and talk
about you know what's wrong because I
wasn't point where I got too into them
where I was just putting voiceover I was
just riffing yet uh but I couldn't help
it at this point I mean this is the
point where it's like we could just talk
about every plot hole in this movie with
them talking back and forth and do it
and so sort of alien language and it
still makes no sense I mean nothing
about those aliens makes a movie make
changes in movie but I digress
um the it's them trying to break into
the house and they boarded up the you
know windows with wood and of course
whenever they come across it they go
wood or in the alien language dugal and
they're just terrifying they just don't
the wood advanced alien shits I could
come down and terrifying it would be
gathered in a water and I'm being a dick
alright alright um so so eventually
there's one point where this noise is
made like you know that tries to you to
do this goal and we were joking when the
aliens try to ram into it with its head
because they forgot to bring weapons or
something sharp or fire you know because
it's like maybe this way they're afraid
of water and put out the fire but I I'm
just try and stop understanding the
logic of that film um and then there's
one point where they're breaking in you
hear them break in you give them walk
upstairs and the family's still talking
it's like they should be running for
shelter or find more wood but you know
they're just
standing there and they don't really
talk about the day you were born instead
the kid doesn't look very intro you
looks very bored uh and and we're just
like are the aliens like so insulted by
this by now it's like dude are you
really just talking over us while we're
trying to break in
aren't we scary at all I mean okay I can
understand I mean it's like that the
wood thing yeah this many sense I need
to go find out about the water and that
that doesn't make a whole lot of sense
but you know what it's like we're trying
come on get you at least lis a bit and
we just work that all into they'll one
scene it's like every stinking plot pole
in that movie not all them gathers even
more but that's what the review is for
so it's just one of those scenes and the
funny thing is that when I did this
review I thought the big thing was going
to be you know I don't remember that
joke I did something with a door it
wasn't the same thing but it's like I'm
like really the adorn can stand or can
stop this alien or something I do this
great big thing and I never got the joke
quite right I do this great big freakout
and I kept trying to re-edit it never
got it right and I was like oh man that
everyone's gonna say I was trying too
hard this review is not good um but it
turns out that scene is really what like
saved that review was those two aliens a
while editing it together I'm like okay
no this is gonna be okay so that's
definitely some good laughs out of that
scene
[Music]
jitka Lukas how can you not go fucking
batshit for Lukas Lukas from the Whizzer
is like one of the craziest characters
and it was so much fun glorifying this
guy his little boy was like obsessed
with Nintendo he's like the cool kid
he's like you know he's like The
Terminator just ate Jesus and he has
Jesus inside of him and now he's powered
by Jesus but because he's a terminator
he's robotic he understands all Nintendo
games and just looking at a Nintendo
game he can win it and why the hell did
I put that in the review that's genius
but so you have this Lucas kid in the
review that they build up and we build
them up even more and we play that calm
music we we have me watching him play
the game and I'm just like fainting
about you know how how incredibly
talented he is you know and just going
so over the top with it and the kid is
so into it that's part of what makes it
so funny
his dog walk is I love the power glove
it's so bad any outcome oh we wouldn't
want you to whiz that anybody it's like
[Music]
of course the joke is you know just how
bad the character is you know how lame
over-the-top but they're so convinced
how cool he is that he actually in a
strange way becomes kind of cool you
know they like the geek cultures so it's
very cool of geeks so yeah I think so
much of it just comes from the way that
character was written the way they
played the music around him and just how
seriously that kid took it so and we
just played it up as much as we could
and we didn't even need to that boy
Jimmy asked all those where the movie
just has half the jokes right there and
yeah every single time I had to do a
riff on icon this year
and and we were on just every time Lucas
popped up I mean all the way we're just
like it was some of the men were like
that too so
[Music]
reading Fifty Shades of Grey all right
this is from the baby geniuses to review
and what was happening here is that I
knew that in this review I wanted to do
something with with rental flaws and
uncle yo cuz I've been to accounts with
both of them they're both phenomenally
funny I thought it'd be great if they
were just constantly in it I just had
this running joke that they would
constantly every time they're trying to
snap me out of it they get distracted by
wine read Fifty Shades of Grey so we had
this and then I think team four star was
at this kind of a second epic on and
they had an 18 and above panel and one
of the things they were doing I forget
it they already had the book or if I had
the book or how it worked but I crashed
it I came in and we talked about reading
Fifty Shades of Grey in different voices
so we started doing that you can still
see it on YouTube it's it's like a four
or five part video it's very very funny
I mean you thought the voices at the end
of this video we're funny I mean watch
this YouTube video I mean you'll laugh
your ass off that guy's Nikolas Cage I
actually fell to the ground laughing in
this video because it was so funny but I
digress
so it went over really really well
people were just howling at it and we
must have done for like an hour just
these different voices and people just
could not get enough of it we couldn't
get enough of it
so it's finally you know what we should
just work this into the video because
original is just gonna end with me Brent
and Cara on the bed reading Fifty Shades
of Grey and then really I was like do
you guys have the time to come up and
shoot this real fast yeah yeah so we
just decided which voice everyone was
gonna do and the rest was just
improvised we just found a page we
thought would be funny and went from
there and that whole ending and you can
proudly tell you know is improvised and
even though they were we're doing the
high fives and everything and then we
all get up and leave I mean we just get
to go in and go and and it's just so
funny
I think people take that clip even just
they don't even watch for us a review
they just take that clip and put it on
YouTube is something like seven or eight
grown men
reading Fifty Shades of Grey on a hotel
it's like yes please click any
impressions are so funny and everyone in
it is so funny laughing is so funny and
I think it's just a genuinely it feels
very genuine just we're all having a
good time people are having fun watching
us they have a good time they're
laughing at the jokes and not the jokes
the yeah the impressions just the
writing and they have good memories of
that con and I have good memories of the
people and filming that and it was just
it was great fun and I think it comes
through in the video and other people
get great fun from it as well
[Music]
Kasbah this was the first con I ever
went to and I said I want to make a
splash um
so pretty much we went in I knew I knew
I had to do something I've never been to
a con and I I wanted to go to more hey
you know so might as well make my mark
somehow and I knew I was like okay well
and it was during the weekend which is
usually why I shot the NC so I knew it's
like okay I have to write this in
somehow and I just had this idea where
I'd be chasing Casper at the end of it
so I told the people I said okay just at
the end of this panel I'm gonna come in
and we're gonna start filming and I can
tell you what's going on I just want you
to go with it I don't know
and so I leave I get in my Ghostbuster
outfit I just come in and just like you
know where's Casper have you seen Casper
he's over like get down I'll get that
and we just kept going and going every
mirror before we start filming I took a
look and I saw the pool there I just
arrived I was like you know Rob I think
I'm gonna have to jump in that pool and
he just went back he's not gonna stop me
it'll be good Internet and so I just got
the crowd going and following me and
stuff like that and animating the Casper
in there and I think it was so great
because it was just such a rush of
people and actually thinking our panel
was going on out there which we
interrupted which I do kind of feel bad
about but um yeah we were just rushing
and doing all this stuff and I think
just how much the people got into it as
well as I did how much they were willing
to go along with how myself were willing
to stay in character is like a joke on a
Harley and they were staying in
character the whole time and it was just
it was great having that energy it was
great going in not knowing how is gonna
turn out either I didn't know if we were
gonna get thrown out or what um and just
knowing and the way we shot Rob is so
good Edie you know sort of that live you
know capturing the video and stuff cuz
he always knows where to point the
camera and who to
and at what point and he gets this stuff
just in time and just at the right
angles and it's tough to do because you
got a crowd of people and everyone
shouting something and you not what was
that funny to go over here is this
person you know and even watching me
because I'll I'll just go for whatever
somebody's saying it's some like switch
focus is that he's so good at capturing
that it really comes through in that
video and it's just so funny as such a
good ending to that review and I really
do think it's moment best reviews that's
just a great end to that character to
antic Casper although of course he never
truly ends you know with the timing joke
but yeah it was you know so much fun to
do it looks great gets a great reaction
ton of fun
[Music]
daddy did digital kitty this comes from
a really funny that this is pretty funny
review this is not one of those I didn't
quite make the top 11 favorite reviews
that's pretty close and I think this was
like my favorite joke for a long it's
time because I love the lead-in I love
it's watching these two women fight each
other in mud and they get dirtier and
dirtier and it's just and their clothes
are getting ripped and they're getting
tighter and they're getting it's like
obviously it's fanservice I mean it's
like you know there's no doubt about it
the character that she's fighting in
like I don't even know she comes back or
what she was or anything and it just
starts with me you know talk about how
stupid it is and it's starting to get
you know turned on by a gang into it and
then Bargo comes in I push him out of
the way all right so that's one thing
and then he comes in again and then
another friend comes in and then my
brother comes then we're all watching
it's just getting more and more into and
we just start screaming and yelling and
getting into it just everyone shouting
something different if you go back and
watch the video what everyone is saying
is funny you know and it's pretty funny
you know oh we should do this every week
I think at one point bribe just goes
wowzers and it's so wonderful finally
when I say shut up Bargo keeps going not
realizing that we've all gone quiet yes
and we all just look at him like he's
insane you can probably tell we're
trying not to crack up and it's just a
great moment of just somebody cuz you
know like I said we everybody shot
something different during one of those
scenes and just to hear what one person
is saying throughout that whole thing
especially knowing that everyone else is
gonna quiet and they can hear him it's
just hilarious it's just so funny and he
is so into it I mean you just see I mean
he's just I think the way it came across
and we were gonna do a sketch where
somebody just hears in the other room
daddy daddy they took Kitty and oh yes
no I'm gonna touch you all over
oh yes it's gonna make you clean on time
person looks really concerned and then
turns out inside is a person just
cleaning their cat pretty much uh so we
can never figure out how to work that in
but we just loved Bargo saying daddy
they don't kitty and a lot of times what
we want him to recreate something he
usually couldn't so the fact that he
could actually get get at that time and
say just as good as he usually did it
was just such a epic laughs
you know you sometimes like of the cons
that bring like autograph prints and one
of them is dirty little kitty and it's
oh it makes me laugh so hard it's just I
think it's a great joke joke is
mara Wilson I know I've gone
friggin on and on about this woman like
a million times but this is my favorite
joke it just is and I and how well she
gets into it and how much she throws our
all into it and and just the ability to
bring out these videos yeah of me as a
you know as a young kid especially had a
point when everyone was like they saw
something videos I put out before and
they're like oh they're not that bad for
that age it's actually pretty good and
blah blah blah so he's thinking to
myself one day I'll show you the bad
snow like the really bad stuff and that
was the time to finally show it and
again I think a lot of people know the
story behind the whole Mauro wilson
thing where there was a misunderstanding
she thought I was being really serious
about the stuff and then when she found
out that you know I wasn't she you know
was very apologetic I'm sorry I'm sorry
and then there was talk about possibly
doing you know like a some sort of
crossover or something and we brought up
she was so enthusiastic about it and it
just made for I think the funniest
moment in fact I think my funniest
probably the funniest thing I ever said
in any of the shows honestly it's just
her name when she first appears I think
the build-up of talking about her for so
long and then suddenly as she appears I
mean as an adult which like nobody on
line has seen I mean like practically
nobody has seen her as an adult and for
her to appear I just look at her I just
go mara Wilson I mean it's just this
clarification of yes you are seeing a
grown-up mara Wilson she is in this
video she has this unbelievably good
sense of humor to go along with this up
here
and done something that she hasn't done
for years which is you know up here on
video and you know and and put it out
there for everyone to see and it's just
so funny and I I don't know what to say
about because I've said so much about it
and it was probably the most fun I ever
had editing something it's the
some of the most time I've ever put into
editing something cuz I wanted to be
just right you know and the review
itself it's very funny and I worked very
hard on it and edited a lot but I mean
it was like hours and hours of editing
that last like two minutes maybe and and
the laughs and the don't fuck with Maura
Wilson and it's just you know thank God
people can have such a good sense of
humor and they can open up and they can
take a chance with something and it you
know all because of jokes all because
you know people just want to have fun
with stuff and make other people feel
better for comedy and it's just it's
just the coolest thing and who the fuck
would have thought you know growing up
if you told me while I was a little kid
watching mrs. Doubtfire you're gonna
have a scene with that little girl right
there when she grows up I believe that
and she's gonna school you and she's
gonna turn to the devil in her eyes are
gonna glow and stuff like that it's
gonna be this huge thing I mean it's
it's a great job where you can come true
and that can happen and it's a great
world where people like that can agree
to it and say yeah let's let's do this
because it's funny and it's just it's
it's a joke that's not only hilarious
but I think it's so pushy in a good mood
because it just shows what can come out
of essentially what started off as a
negative situation and you know could
could turn into something childish and
mean but instead you turn into something
smart and funny and that's it it's a
joke that just puts me in a good mood on
top of just making me laugh it just puts
me in a good mood just knowing just
knowing this world is so strange
that stuff like that can happen so I
think I've gone on long and long enough
next week you are going to see the first
episode of demo reel that will be coming
out - it will be a special one-hour
episode and yeah I've had a lot of fun
talking about these and talk about the
nostalgia critics and all that good
stuff and
hopefully you guys like what's coming up
next so hope everything's going good in
your lives and I should talk to you
later